yes come on three okay one two three
with the tumors handling controversial
social issues all in the family was a
truly groundbreaking TV show and it was
just one of the mega hits greenlit by
legendary TV executive Fred Silverman
who died this week at the age of 82
Silverman had an extraordinary career
heading up the entertainment divisions
at all three networks of the day CBS ABC
and MBC his knack for picking successful
shows led Time magazine to dub him the
man with the golden gut he loved
television he loved the challenge of
trying to come up with a television show
that would resonate with America
Silverman the future fixer of networks
was himself the son of a TV and radio
repairman by the age of 25 he was
director of daytime programming here at
CBS one of his pet projects a cartoon
concept he came up with about a group of
kids in their dog who hunts ghosts and
of course became scooby-doo in his early
30s Silverman took over primetime at CBS
boldly canceling popular sitcoms like
The Beverly Hillbillies and Green Acres
and replacing them with more
sophisticated fare like mash
the Mary Tyler Moore Show and all in the
family spin-offs Maude and The
Jeffersons Fred had real foresight into
seeing where television was going and
time proved that that he was right in
1975 Silverman left CBS to become
president of ABC where he greenlit
Three's Company Charlie's Angels The
Love Boat and the landmark miniseries
Roots catapulting ABC to number one
three years later Silverman was wooed to
NBC
he had hits like Hill Street Blues but
failed to bring the peacock Network to
number one after leaving NBC he became a
producer turning out hit dramas like
Matlock for all three broadcast networks
really did have an incredible knack for
knowing what am I
I wanted to watch talking about that
knack he heard a comedian at a dinner
one night liked them so much he hired
him in 1980 gave him his own show that
comedian David letter